[Musique]
la rive gauche à la rive droite le pont
alexandre iii mène les parisiens de
l'esplanade des invalides à la seule rue
de paris qui n'est pour riverains que
deux palais en vis-à-vis le grand et le
petit palais
grands et petits palais qui constitue
avec le pont alexandre iii
un ensemble exemplaire de style 1900
construit par les architectes de glaner
thomas à l'occasion de l'exposition 1900
sur les champs elysées le grand palais
est admirable pour bien des raisons qui
à paris ne connaît du grand palais cet
étonnant morceau de bravoure
[Musique]
le grand palais est en vérité une
étonnante construction la partie de
pierre c'est à dire toutes les façades
ne semble être que l' enveloppe à
l'intérieur de laquelle l'édifice de fer
et de verre est admirable motte
architecture et sur 200 m de long 55 m
de large et 60 mètres de haut mais tout
léger et tout solide qu'il soit le grand
palais n'en a pas moins 70 ans des
réparations importantes s'imposer il
fallait plus encore savoir comment
compte tenu de l'évolution des choses et
des besoins
ce grand palais hall d'exposition idéal
mais ne répondant plus aux exigences
actuelles comment ce grand palais
seraient utilisés il fallait en tous les
cas respecter cet extraordinaire
architecture 1900
le grand palais et le décor idéal d'un
film et pas seulement d'un film 1900
emballé est également actuellement le
théâtre de travaux gigantesques
rénovation du grand palais mais aussi
découverte du grand palais de ce qu'il
est et de ce qu'il sera il serait et
nous allons le voir
il sera le lieu où se tiendra dès
l'automne prochain dans des salles
entièrement refaite
le premier grand hommage à picasso pour
ses 85 ans hommage qui se tiendra en
cette salle la salle d'exposition la
plus moderne de paris dans le palais le
plus vénérable un homme à l'origine
monsieur reynolds arnould en tant que
conservateur des musées de france et de
conservateurs des galeries nationales
d'exposition du grand palais il s'agit
pour répondre à ce qu'impliquent ces
deux termes d'avoir à le transformer en
un véritable palais des expositions
temporaires c'est à dire
muni de tous les moyens d'exposition qui
permettent dans les délais les plus
rapides afin d'assurer une activité qui
correspondent à l'importance de sa tâche
de moyens suffisamment souple
suffisamment flexible pour aussi
permettre d'accueillir des expositions à
caractère très divers ayant enfin étant
le reflet de discipline
différentes clients souvent des
commissaires généraux particulier de
pouvoir enfin donner à ces expositions
tout le caractère culturel le plus
étendu
c'est à dire de n'être pas seulement d
exposition qui présente l'oeuvre d'art
pour l'importance qu'elle a en tant que
chef-d'oeuvre car il s'agira toujours de
chefs-d'oeuvre qu'ils soient d'hier
d'aujourd'hui mais de telle manière que
sur le plan de la culture en général
soit puisse être satisfait les besoins
les plus précis plan études recherche de
reynolds arnould réanimateurs plus
encore que conservateur du grand palais
un immense et passionnant chantier
inconnu du public tel est le grand
palais véritable petite cité où en dépit
de ces travaux vous pouvez visiter en ce
moment les installations permanentes les
expositions temporaires du palais de la
découverte
l'exposition de l'art [ __ ] qui nous
vient de dakar et voir travailler les
étudiants architectes et les étudiants
de la faculté des lettres
lorsque les travaux du grand palais
travaux si bien commencé seront terminés
ce n'est pas seulement paris mais la
france qui sera doté d' appât les
d'exposition digne de son passé et de
son présent
un homme conduit ces travaux
l'architecte en chef monsieur vivier
il pourrait vous paraître curieux de
voir cette architecture contemporaine
dans cet édifice qui date de l'époque
1900 c'est que nous avons deux
caractéristiques au grand palais cette
magnifique architecture de fer et de
vence est ainsi texture de faire
contrairement à ce qu'on voyait au
crystal palace à londres
nous avons toute une série de façade en
pierre qui masque au fond cette
architecture donc à l'intérieur de ces
galeries dans des locaux qui n'avaient
pas larchitecture il ne pouvait être
question dure créer une architecture de
l'époque et il fallait résolument créer
une architecture fonctionnelle mobile
totalement mobile de façon à répondre au
but et à la mobilité que doit avoir que
peuvent avoir de nos jours des locaux
d'exposition temporaire bonjour vieux
grand palais
[Musique]